depuis cet après midi pierre et marie
curie sont les 70e et 71e grands hommes
comme l'on dit admis au panthéon
la cérémonie officielle que vous avez pu
suivre en direct sur france 2 a été
présidée par françois mitterrand devant
un parterre de personnalités parmi
lesquelles edouard balladur et jacques
chirac commentaire jean-claude
halakhique un choix symbolique pour
porter les deux cercueils de pierres et
de marie curie celui de 12 étudiants en
physique et en chimie futurs chercheurs
et pour les accompagner des lycéens qui
rappellent à leur manière la découverte
du polonium et du radium et des rayons
alpha et bêta qu'il allures de prix
nobel aux écuries ou rendre cet hommage
de la nation françois mitterrand qui
serre la main ou premier ministre
candidat et au maire de paris candidat
sous l'oeil d'un troisième candidat
robert hue
sous l'oeil aussi d'escury fille de
pierre et de marie et third irène joliot
curie la seule de la famille à avoir
choisi le journalisme en plus tôt que la
science c'est le prix nobel de physique
pierre gilles de gennes qui devait
rappeler l'importance fondamentale de la
découverte de la radioactivité
marie formule alors son hypothèse au
combien audacieuse
il y aurait dans la presse ce plan d'
une impureté les impuretés dans
trouveront plusieurs
la première portera le nom de son pays
aimer et imprimer ce sera le premier la
pologne natale de marie et skoda ce cas
serait évoquée par le cheval isaac qui
rappellera l'engagement patriotique de
la jeune femme
quant à françois mitterrand soulignera
que c'est aussi la première fois qu'une
femme entreprend t on en est en or et un
pour ses propres mérites mais il est un
autre symbole qui retient ce soir
l'attention de la nation que ces
honneurs d'exprimer devant vous
celui du combat exemplaire d'une femme
qui a décidé d'imposer ses capacités
dans une société qui réserve aux hommes
les fonctions intellectuelles et les
responsabilités publiques
enfin qui les réserves trop souvent
ce soir marie la jeune étudiante
polonaise devenus deux fois prix nobel
pour la france oppose au panthéon à deux
pas de la sorbonne nous il fut la
première femme à enseigner ya deux pas
du laboratoire où il découvrit le radium
avec pierre curie au fronton de
l'histoire ils ont désormais rejoint qg
berthelot voltaire rousseau ou zola et
jaurès
donc